giant penis sand monsters a day at the
spa an aquaman in the desert it's been
37 years since david lynch's theatrical
version of dune was released and patrick
stewart went off to war holding a pug
[Music]
unfortunately that son of a gun
villeneuve decided not to put that in
the new version in this video we'll be
going over the ending of doom part 1
paul's cryptic visions and how
villeneuve's version might change from
both the book and 1984 film adaptation
so ride my worm as we delve into arrakis
and make sure to like and subscribe or
else i'll be forced to include clips of
anakin skywalker hating sand i don't
like sand and spoiler warning ahead as
i'll be going over some plot points from
dune and children of dune i'll also be
using the frank herbert pronunciations
of the character names you might be
taken a bit off guard because dune part
1 ends rather abruptly our protagonist
paula tradies has just killed a fremen
warrior named james who invoked the rule
of amtal in the dune books the amtol
rule is summarized as follows to know a
thing well know its limits only when
pushed beyond its tolerances will true
nature be seen there's been some
uncertainty among the fremen whether
paula tradies is the lisend al-gayib a
freeman term for off-world prophet james
does not believe that paul is this
prophet so he wants to as the amtel rule
describes push paul to his limits to see
his true nature if he can strike down
paul then paul surely isn't this prophet
what jameis doesn't know is this scrawny
kid has been trained by the best
fighters in the land's rod both duncan
idaho and gurney hallock additionally he
is the son of a bena jesuit lady jessica
who has trained him in the weirding way
the weirding way isn't mentioned a lot
in dune part 1 but if you've seen the
2003 mini-series children of dune you'll
see james mcavoy's character lato
atreides ii use it when battling his
ant's royal guards the weirding way
allows for this short teleportation-like
ability not seen in part 1. it's unclear
whether villeneuve will utilize this
with paul in part two we do however see
other benedesperate influences on paul
such as his training with the voice in
his first scene with jessica he's tasked
with using it to command his mother to
pass him a glass of water if only i had
that ability when i played world of
warcraft to get my mom to bring me pizza
pops
paul's ability to tap into different
futures and hear voices from the past
present and future can be seen when a
voice tells him to quote follow the
friend as we see him being trained by
james a future that does not happen we
don't exactly know who is behind this
voice but if i were to hazard a guess it
comes from what's referred to as other
memory in the dune universe other memory
is the idea that an individual may
possess the memories of their ancestors
hidden away within their genetic code it
could be his ancestors guiding him along
this path but i want to get back to this
term lisan al-gaib it's derived from
arabic and in the context of islam means
tongue of the unseen dimensions of
reality whoever is this prophet can see
into endless futures and guide humanity
along its path as paul in the children
of doon miniseries says i meddled in the
future
in all possible futures
trying to create them the bene jesuit
called this prophet the kwitsats hadarak
believing that this person will lead
humanity down a golden path of peace for
10 000 years they've been a jesuit have
carried out a selective breeding program
in an effort to produce this profit the
beneficiary believed that the prophet's
time was soon upon them and if duke lado
and lady jessica produced a female heir
they could marry her off to a hearkening
male and their child would become the
quitsat's hadarac
you were told to bear only daughters but
you and your pride thought you could
produce the quizadz
was i wrong but lady jessica went
against the wishes of the bene jesuit
and bore later a son paul in the dune
universe at benejesser can choose the
sex of their child it isn't until paul
is tested by the reverend mother helen
mohaym that she believes paul might be
the one that's why she goes to baron
vladimir harkenin and asks him to spare
jessica and paul when they attack
arrakis when paul ingests spice during
the spice harvester rescue he is haunted
by voices which echo the words kwitsat's
hattera
and before he fights jamas we hear this
in one of his visions
i argue this is more of a metaphorical
death paul will need to cast aside his
old name to become something new in the
novel paul takes the name wadeeb this is
derived from the small mouse of the
desert which we see in part one one of
the most cryptic parts of dune part 1
are paul's visions now i actually
extracted every vision and put them in
chronological order because i'm a crazy
person so that i could get a better
grasp of what's going on here the first
thing to note are that the visions
aren't a hundred percent accurate in
fact they can be completely wrong paul
dreams of both pajamas teaching him in
the desert and james killing him neither
of these are true the dreams are merely
several of the possible futures paul
could encounter the 1984 film confirms
the unreliability of these visions your
mother wants you to tell me about your
dreams
do they come
true not all of them
i know which ones will believe it or not
there are roughly four to five minutes
of paul's visions scattered throughout
the film appearing in most of these
visions is chaney she'll later become
paul's lover and father of his children
not seen in the 1984 version but likely
to appear in part 2 paul and cheney have
a son who is killed by beast rabban
harkonnen this might be what spurs paul
and the fremen in their final attack
against the harkonnen and the emperor we
do get this vision of paul taking on the
sardakar which could be part of the epic
battle of arakin which occurs at the end
of dune and sees paul become emperor i
love how you can even see a sandworm
fighting alongside them in this vision
it's chaney who guides him into battle
but in the 1984 version she's battling
alongside him which i think is more
likely to happen in part two as well we
also see a vision of jessica holding a
baby we know that she's pregnant with
paul's sister in the books jessica takes
the water of life while pregnant i won't
get into too much detail but the water
of life allows a bene gesserate to
ascend to reverend mother granting them
far greater powers this ascension causes
jessica to prematurely give birth and
the process gives her a daughter who
will come to be known as alia alia will
have incredible powers similar to her
brother paul and will play a pivotal
role in dune part 2. she's the one who
will actually kill baron harkin and not
mentioned in the film that baron is
actually her grandfather for those of
you who don't know jessica is the
illegitimate child of the baron which
would also make paul his grandson
perhaps most cryptic of the visions is
chaney's bloody hand and the kris knife
made from a tooth of a sandworm it's
implied here that she's the one to kill
paul this never happens in the dew novel
and i interpret this as one of two
things a a future that does not happen
or be a metaphor for the blood on paul's
hands when he begins his crusade across
the galaxy after the events of dune paul
becomes emperor but not everyone is too
excited about that he embarks on a
crusade which at the beginning of the
children of dune mini-series has already
killed 60 billion people now you might
be asking yourself i thought paul was
this nice guy fighting for justice how
is this possible well because paul can
see into the future he has to navigate
humanity in such a way that prevents its
own annihilation and part of this path
means embarking on a crusade but here we
see that young paul hates what future
paul has become i see a holy war
spreading across the universe like
unquenchable fire a warrior religion
that weighs the atreides banner in my
father's name if you want to learn more
about what happens after the events of
dune i suggest you check out both my
dune 1984 and children of dune videos
paul makes the decision to stay on dune
even after his mother suggested they be
smuggled off planet he tells the fremen
that the atreides came to dune not for
the spices or riches but for the
strength of its people desert power the
emperor sent the atreides to dune to die
so paul will stay and fight back you may
also recall that this woman kines was
tasked with getting off planet and
telling various houses of the landsrod
who would be sympathetic to the atreides
of the betrayal that occurred on arrakis
and that paul is still alive this would
undoubtedly cause a civil war within the
empire to avoid this paul throws out the
suggestion he marry one of the emperor's
daughters since the emperor has no male
heirs this would unite the two warring
factions although this is quickly
dismissed by his mother and kinds this
will become a reality later on for him
when he ascends to emperor he'll marry
princess ireland carino one of the
emperor's daughters this is a political
marriage to help keep the peace and he's
still very much in love with cheney and
the two end up having twins paul ends up
seeing a friend and warrior riding a
sand worm what kinds was trying to do
before she was cut down by the sardakar
he refers to this ability as desert
power the same thing his father wanted
to unlock on arrakis in the 84 version
of dune you'll see how paul will
eventually be able to ride worms and
control them something that will prove
worthwhile when taking on the emperor
but the last line of the film goes to
cheney who says this is only the
beginning and for paul it is this is the
beginning of his journey to become
muadib the kwitsat's hararak which part
2 will delve into as of today an imdb
page has just been made for dune part 2
which has the synopsis duke paula
tradies joins the freeman and begins a
spiritual and martial journey to become
muadeeb while trying to prevent the
horrible but inevitable future he's
witnessed a holy war in his name
spreading throughout the universe i
don't know about you guys but i
absolutely love this version of dune and
if you're looking for more content i
have three other videos from differences
between this version and 1984 as well as
ending explains for children of dune and
the 84 version so be sure to check those
out thanks for watching everyone make
sure to like and subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at thingstoryt until next
time remember daddy loves you very much